là alors dès ce soir bien nous allons
ouvrir le feu avec un premier reportage
qui est pour une fois je crois que le
mot n'est pas trop fort une véritable
exclusivité vous avez rencontré jean
patrick manchette manchette est un homme
qu'on ne voit pas qu'il ne veut plus
parler et il est vrai que pour les
téléspectateurs de la région et à
l'occasion de ce festival il vous a
accordé une interview
jean patrick manchette il faut le
présenter c'est un homme de 41 ans est
un écrivain de polars c'est un post
soixante huitard pour parler comme par
les professionnels
c'est un gauchiste il se dit gauchistes
et il est à la tête de 10 ans de ce
qu'on a appelé les néo polar et
manchettes depuis une dizaine d'années
depuis dix ans oui sa dernière
apparition date de 73 et c'était dans la
peau strophes n'a jamais accordé
d'interview télévisée parce qu'il est
agoraphobe
il est est la fouille ne veut pas il est
le fuient le contact mais c'est pourtant
un grand écrivain ou hamouma n'êtes pas
bien sûr mais c'est un grand écrivain
scénariste prisé par les producteurs et
les réalisateurs
il a signé le scénario de la crimée
dernier namm ça marche bien ça marche
bien pour lui il est très recherchée et
mais bon bah ils les tests la presse il
n'aime pas trop la presse
alors ce reportage c'est la somme de
plusieurs mois de démarches de coups de
téléphone il accepté de se raconter
nous sommes allés le rencontrer à paris
c'est raconter vous allez le voir il ya
beaucoup de choses à raconter
il faut l'écouter
je voulais être écrivain de signer mois
et personne ne voulait lire mes sujets
que je souffre j'avais porté aux
producteurs alors j'en ai fait des
livres en m'élisant avec la belle
assurance de la jeunesse si c'est un
bouquin ça les impressionnera ils
achèteront du droit je deviendrai
adaptateur de mes propres mains
ça a marché parfaitement que j'ai été
très étonné parce que je me suis aperçu
que m'intéressait beaucoup plus
finalement à au bouquin que j'écrivais
que cook à l'écriture de cinéma au début
je pensais faire simplement comme comme
les grands américains qui faisaient du
réalisme critique
de la critique sociale à travers des à
travers des romans d'action qui écrivait
sur la crise de 29 et sur le
gangstérisme sur le criminel
criminalisation du syndicalisme des
choses comme ça je me suis dit il n'y a
qu'à faire pareil j'ai au début j'ai eu
l'impression que j'essaie de faire un
peu pareil
et puis après je me suis mis à me
prendre la tête a donné en me disant
mais non ça ne peut pas être tout à fait
pareil parce que il était dans une
certaine période entre les deux guerres
où la perspective historique tu es
complètement bouché m'en allais une
deuxième guerre mondiale il y avait
appris aux moi au contraire je suis en
train d'écrire de l'après-68 dans un
moment
les perspectives de changement social un
peu partout
donc ça va être la même chose et depuis
je gratte je me demande comment je fais
pour utiliser un style que le style de
l'époque précédente
comment je fais pour l'utiliser
maintenant dans cette époque c'est
comment arrivez-vous à dix avant de
relâcher la cei et je vais commencer un
peu la salle est très très longtemps à
mûrir
parce que généralement sa part d'une
abstraction complète je pars pas d'une
intrigue ou de faits divers ou de
personnages eux mais je me dis ah ben
tiens j'ai envie de dire quelque chose
sur le terrorisme
ce que j'en pense où je me dis comme je
suis en train de faire en ce moment en
fait depuis six mois un an
j'ai envie de parler du cinéma qu'est ce
que c'est le cinéma quel effet ça fait
comment ça fonctionne et je pars sur
l'année comme ça
personnellement je me dis j'ai envie de
faire unique elke chose qui traite du
cinéma ça ne me donne pas du tout
la polar alors j'attends y ait des
incidents qui dit m sur l'oeil que j'ai
un thème d'action que j'ai envie de
mélanger avec le thème abstrait que j'ai
eu au départ mais en revanche à partir
de là il absorbe tout ce qui vous tombe
sous la main je lis des faits divers
n'importe quel bouquin je vois n'importe
quel film ce quelque chose va se
détacher de ce que je vois et venir
s'agglutiner à mon idée progressivement
mais un trip qui se forme je commence à
avoir des gens et des actions tout ça
est relié mais ça ça se fait tout seul
pour ainsi dire on tout ça est relié g
j'ai un peu là y'a plus qu'à l'écrire
comme dirait l'autre
alors comme vous c'est quoi le polar
sept ans c'est un genre de livre qui est
des ses origines produits directement
pour le marché des produits directement
pour être vendus il pas produit par
quelqu'un qui a un mécène par exemple
qui adhérentes qui écrit l'amour de
l'art il est écrit pour nous fait et
dans la maison et écrit pour bouffer
windowsiens la vérité du roman
artistique parce que le roman artistique
aussi est devenu un objet de marché
simplement on cache ça on n'en parle pas
c'est censé être de l'art c'est censé
être noble leur nom artistique ans alors
que c'est devenu une fois d'ailleurs on
fait des fois à ce confort et à nice et
ailleurs ils comptaient pour le
romantique
le polar où ça me paraît presque plus
franc et cette pub
nous avançons visant
je suis de la littérature alimentaire et
ça permet à ce moment-là de contourner
l'adversaire et au lieu d'être un
malheureux écrivain d'art qui est traqué
par les questions du marché on est un
minable l'auteur de polars rien qu'un
auteur de polars et puis en secret
pendant qu'on raconte cette histoire de
l'areuse avec la cud flux tout ça on est
en train de travailler sur le texte
personne ne le sait
mais quand il se trouve que je suis
beaucoup allé aussi les mains fait
partie de la génération tracy necid à
peu près la même génération ils y boit
c'est par exemple un petit peu plus
jeunes de légende est gay finalement il
est tout seul je pratique ma génération
qui s'est passionné pour le cinéma de la
nouvelle vague et d'autre part pour tout
le cinéma hollywoodien des gens comme
toi coulé au sternum
oui bah je passais mon temps à 100 j'ai
eu la chance d'être tranquillement
étudiants pendant trois ans et au mieux
d'aller au lieu d'aller à mes courses à
lui aussi les mains gelées la
cinémathèque et je me suis rempli de du
sein
le cinéma est venu nous rions ce que
j'écrivais ce qui peut parfois de gênant
sécher en train de travailler sur un
film j'ai toujours des réminiscences qui
me viennent il faut pas trop que je me
mette à citer
dans ce que je fais on essaie de faire
quelque chose d'original dans les
bouquins dont j'ai plaisir à citer en
sachant que je cite et en décalant les
choses et si dans tel bouquin je fais
exploser une station d'essence
je suis en train de penser au camion
d'essence qu'ils explosent dans la fin
de la célèbre séquence de l'avion dans
la mort aux trousses de hitchcock tient
en sa et souviens toi qui puisse appeler
en otage était un petit gros avec des
moustaches un allemand
parce qu'on est le cioa zaher c'est pas
une fourchette que j'ai dans la main et
ça va ça va commencer tu le fais déjà
ici parce que nous a prévenus bananes
les employés qu'ils annoncent un labour
ne gardant ce gars tu peux pas penser à
tout ne bougez pas cinéma a adopté un
certain nombre de vols ivresses était
pas toujours d adaptation très fidèle
ces nouvelles voies non je ne pense pas
que je pense pas qu'il faille que les
adaptations sont fidèles
j'aime bien j'aime bien les frères
karamazov de richard brooks où il y a
il ya une apn je pense que richard
brooks il a fait son truc
le styliste qui avait fait le sien je
vais pas courir après richard brooks
avec un hachoir
faut il dire c'est pas pareil c'est pas
la même chose et c'est mauvais vous avez
tort avec votre apn
j'ai pas non plus courir avec un hachoir
après les gens qui ont voulu faire un
film si jacques deray fait un film
d'après un roman de manchette
il est plutôt comparable nous autres au
film de jacques deray on peut dire que
c'est meilleur ou moins bon qu'un
papillon sur l'épaule de jacques deray
si jacques deray fait d'un homme à
abattre mais pas que c'est meilleur ou
moins bon qu'un peu le livre bon c'est
parti ces deux secteurs différents
encore 50 m tu prends la gauche voilà
voilà où lille et diamants eh ben je
vous embauche pour creuser voilà raconté
à gino comment vous m'avez aidé à la
récupérer robert toi toi l'honneur c'est
vous tu es là
à m allons-y est ce que le fait d'avoir
une certaine répugnance à entrer dans la
foule des prouesses qu'on appelle de
l'agoraphobie est ce que ça vous aide
tout ça vous dessert dans votre travail
d'écrivain
ça m'a aidé pour un bouquin que j'essaie
où j'avais un personnage complètement
caractériel mais
mais ça m'embête parce que lance le
moment ils mm d'ici de les voir sur le
terrain certaines choses j'aimerais les
voir dans quel état et c'est lent parce
que j'ai un personnage qui passe par
l'île de ceylan en admettant que je
puisse m'offrir le voyage je peux pas y
aller
est ce que c'était un petit peu grâce à
vous que pollard est devenu une mode
c'est un peu par ma faute sans doute oui
de toute façon quelqu'un elle faire on
est arrivé d'ailleurs à 12 je suis
arrivé en même temps que mon copain
d'asti de la dg d'arrivée trois mois
plus tard jean vautrin de trois mois
après ainsi de suite
donc toute façon il fallait quelqu'un de
facile c'est d'autant que ce soit moi